[Music]
look there's a bird
[Music]
every time
look there's a dog there's no dog
[Music]
what
[Music]
hey
i told you there was a dog
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh come on higher left
[Music]
good luck
[Music]
[Applause]
are you okay
[Music]
hey emil how's it going hey ready to
play first i gotta tell you this one
story that happened to me on the way
here can you imagine that a squirrel
with a football in its mouth what if
they've just come from practice place
your fields of iceland and if you add a
bit of black pepper it just really
finishes off the breakfast it's one of
the
it's still warm the water you can bathe
in it really good stuff
[Music]
oh by the way i was playing a tournament
in sicily last year thing they do
between all the points i thought it was
quite interesting
so antonio did he looked the opponent in
the eye as he was doing the circular
motion i think it could help your game
if you stop talking i mean
[Music]
could you pass me the ball over there
[Music]
i got it
ah thanks
don't worry i got it i don't know i
don't know i got it i got it i got it
here you go
thank you
so there's still 76 of you watching who
haven't subscribed so help us get to 3
million and do it now until next time